- I agree, I feel after
reading this paper,
everybody's sort of pushing out,
you need to test, test
and trace trace, right?
And it seems like we're beyond the point,
potentially beyond the point
of tracing at this point.
But is that like did...
So we were thinking about
a place like New Zealand
and I don't know if this
is outside of the realm
of this paper, where they
are they're saying that
they're COVID free.
And is it because they did
these types of efforts,
from the very beginning, if you know?
- I'm not sure.
I think it is partially because
they had stricter lockdown measures
and they made sure
people were wearing masks
and they actually shut everything down.
Cause what happened to the U.S. is,
we didn't actually shut down.
Our testing capacity is very limited.
And part of how contact tracing works.
Cause you need to be able to test people
to say this person has COVID
so that you can actually trace contacts.
- [Anna] Yeah, I think-
- Sorry, go ahead Anna.
- [Anna] Oh, no problem.
I just, I read an interesting article
about contact tracing efforts
that are currently ongoing in Utah.
Was it Utah Devany?
- I think so.
- [Anna] Yeah, and I think
it's just sort of interesting
to think about how in the U.S.,
I think the U.S. is very
heterogeneous, right?
We have a lot of different
States with different approaches,
and I think there are
still places in the U.S.
where the numbers are
still relatively low.
And so I think that's not
to say that contact tracing
may not have any utility
in certain places.
I think especially cause,
as we've learned more about the disease,
like it seems like R0 is
not 3.5, it's a bit lower.
And I think some of the
scenarios we mapped out here
were a little bit extreme.
But yeah, I think it sort of all,
it really seems like
it's been varying a lot,
like country to country and place to place
about what techniques are
really, really feasible
in different situations.
- So I was curious, my husband
who also does math models,
but within cancer has to defend his work
I think a lot to biologists
and people who don't
necessarily understand his work.
But is there a way to kind
of help people understand
where these kinds of
mathematical models fit
within understanding disease
kind of particularly these
kinds of infectious diseases
and how you then compare afterwards to say
yes, this was a legitimate
model for this disease.
- [Anna] Devany do you
want to start with this one
and I can chime in.
- Sure.
So the issue with models,
like all of your teachers
that teach you how to model
discuss is that all models are wrong
because all models are
an over simplification.
It's hard to know I think
how accurate a model is
if you're not actually
implementing all the parameters,
like for this model, for instance,
like this was based on
information that turned
out not to be true,
at least in the U.S. a
lot of, all my research
and reading has been on stuff
that's happening in the U.S.
because this was assuming
that we would have like
a smaller population
and there'd be one or two three four.
Like a limited number of people
who'd come in with the virus.
And in the U.S. at least it seemed like
the number was much, much higher.
So I think that,
it's less about seeing
whether or not the model
is a good model and tuning
the parameters of the model
in order to better match reality
or putting in other pieces
like maybe this person
goes into isolation,
but they occasionally
come out of their house.
And how do you model that?
Now they have a higher
infectivity when they leave
and you have to account for that.
But I think it's about figuring
out what to account for,
and it really depends a lot on the data
that you're gathering.
Cause that is what informs
the creation of your model
in the first place.
I'll say I'm not an expert
on pandemic modeling.
I'm a biophysicist, so I,
everything with a grain of salt
get actual information from experts.
But as someone who's built a
bunch of computational models,
it really, really depends
on the data that you get
and the effectiveness you
have of gathering the data.
- [Anna] I think just as an
individual, looking at models
is a helpful practice to think...
It forces you to think
really specifically about
what are the different factors
that could have an effect
since you have to
explicitly list them out.
And so even just like, as a
person reading this paper,
sometimes you come across factors
that you hadn't thought of yourself,
or people make an assumption and you say,
"Oh, that assumption isn't,
"I don't think that's a good assumption."
And it forces you to think
more about why that's the case.
I think doing this work early
at the start of the pandemic
can be helpful
cause you're sort of exploring
a range of possibilities.
And then once you've laid the groundwork,
as you get more accurate information,
you can feed that into
these existing models.
So hopefully get slightly
more informed not predictions,
cause it's not really predicting
exactly what's gonna happen,
but just more informed models,
more informed pictures of
what might be possible.
And I think also really looking at like
the role of different variables
compared to each other.
I think one thing that
happens when people run models
like this is that they'll see,
they'll test the effect of,
especially when you can vary
two different parameters at once.
You might see that, I
can, changing parameter A,
has a much bigger effect
than changing parameter B.
Even if on their own,
they each have an effect.
There might be a much bigger
effect contribution from one
than the other, and that can help you then
sort of tease apart.
If approach one seems to
have a much more impact,
much greater impact than approach two,
and then maybe it's worth
fueling our resources
into approach one rather than
worrying about approach two.
- Yeah and just for reference.
So most of my husband David's work
is actually talking to biologists
and getting the parameters
you were just talking about.
- And it seems like those parameters
it's like you only know what you know.
And so there's always
something that you don't know
that you're potentially missing.
And so I imagine it's
complicated and hard,
but I also feel like there's
so much value in beauty
and Joanne threw a comment in about
the beauty of a model that
you can plug in the values
based on new information.
And so yeah, I'm grateful for
modeling even though I think,
you're probably right in saying Devany
and everybody who teaches modeling,
"all models wrong", but
it's the best we have
at this point in time.
So we have a question
from Stephanie that says,
did the paper discuss anything
about how long an interaction
between people had to be worth,
had to take place in
order to be worth tracing?
Like if somebody was at the grocery store,
and checked out with a cashier
versus two friends
catching up for 15 minutes.
Is there a difference or
in like how we're thinking
about that for contact tracing.
- [Anna] So I think in practice,
definitely in this paper,
no, correct me if I'm wrong Devany.
But I think they modeled
every contact as identical.
- [Devany] Yeah.
- [Anna] But I know in
practice, that's definitely
something that people
are talking a lot about.
Both in terms of like,
how likely is it that
the disease is spreading
in these momentary interactions.
And also along the axis of how feasible
is it for us to be able
to trace this person?
Cause if you're relying on
people interacted with clearly,
that's a problem.
If they're interacting
with people in passing
at the grocery store other people,
other countries have gotten around that,
like in South Korea, by
using digital tracking
and accessing people's GPS signals
and credit card information
like the government doing this,
to be able to see where people were going
in relation to each other.
Clearly that's not something
that's like politically
feasible in the U.S.
that people wouldn't be comfortable with.
So I think that sort of hearkens
back to our earlier point
that I think you need different approaches
in different locations.
It's not a one size fits all situation.
- It feels like there could
be a very slippery slope
if we give access to our
personal data to government
people it seems like, I don't know,
I'm not sure it's worth the risk.
I might, that's my personal opinion,
but at least at this point in time.
- [Anna] I think the great thing though,
is once you have a model like this,
that that is the type of
question that you could then
build on this model to incorporate.
So what we presented today
is these are the assumptions
and the setup that these
researchers decided to go with.
But this isn't the only way
that they could have chosen to do this.
And if you're coding savvy
and downloaded the simulation,
you could go and, it probably
would be kind of difficult,
but you could go and add
on some of these components
to the existing simulation
to see what effect they have.
- Yeah, you could model things like
if you have a weak contact,
the percent chance that you're
gonna pass on the disease,
it's like halved or quartered
or something like that,
or you have a strong contact,
it could be go way off.
And that's sort of how
you could model that.
But in this model they did
not take that into account,
but it's a sort of a baseline
for building more complex
models in the future.
- [Anna] And in this model,
they do actually take into
account for certain variables,
the fact that inter,
but these are not the
same for every person.
So we didn't describe this
in detail, but for example,
for the onset to isolation delay
they weren't just plugging in three days
or eight days for every person.
They actually had like a distribution
that they sampled from that
was centered at three days
for the short delay and
centered at eight days
for the long delay.
But you could still get like
seven day delay, ten day delay,
three day delay, for
different interactions
in the simulation.
So there is a little bit more complexity
that you can build in.
- So Susan wants to know, is
the contact tracing dependent
on the reporting of the
infected individual?
- I think it depends
on like Anna was saying
the country you're in.
So here, I believe it would be,
cause I don't think you can
get information like that.
You can't get someone's
credit card data to figure out
like what grocery stores they've been to.
So you'd have to say, "Who
have you been in contact with?"
And like, do you have their phone number?
- Tech companies like, sorry, I'm sorry-
- No, go for it.
- For your stopping.
But aren't there, like, does
didn't Apple like have a thing
where if somebody, somebody can
input themselves as positive
and if they've come into
proximity of other iPhone users,
that there would be some alert.
- Oh, wow.
I didn't know that.
- [Anna] I was reading
about this recently.
I'm not a hundred percent.
My understanding of
what's happened is that
Apple and Google actually teamed up.
And they've built an API
which is sort of like a data interface
that you use via the internet.
And so they created this API.
That's supposed to be helpful
in coordinating that type of information.
But they have not built any
sort of unified app to do this.
And so they released it to the States
and States individually
then have the ability
for the responsibility
to develop their own app
using this API to do the tracing.
But I think as someone
mentioned in the comments,
I think there has been pushback on this.
And there are a number of
States who have attempted
to try and do this, but I
think it hasn't actually,
I don't know if it's actually
been rolled out anywhere.
I think there have been some issues.
- It feels like a task
that only Apple or Google
can actually accomplish.
I'm not sure, like for example,
New York state has like,
a whole tech angle or office
that could build things
like this without at
least on top of the work
that they already have.
It seems, it's an interesting idea
and I'm not familiar with
how that risks privacy,
but it feels like we
have so much technology
and so many tech giant that like,
I wish that we were doing
more to incorporate that
into everything.
- [Anna] I think Taiwan I
don't remember the details,
but I believe that Taiwan
developed some sort of
app or some sort of system
that wasn't even, I think
it was more of like a...
There's sort of a history,
I think, of the Taiwanese government
kind of almost
collaborating with different
like hacker individuals
within the community.
And so I think this
was another partnership
kind of similar to that
where it maybe wasn't as like
government led necessarily,
but it was sort of this collaboration
where they put out this call
and got people to work on this together.
- I think there is a really
important balance between,
peoples' privacy concerns,
using things like Apple and Google
versus handing it over to the government.
I don't necessarily feel
comfortable with either personally,
but the UK decided that they,
I think Apple and Google offered to make
this app, they created it.
And then they said, well, we
don't really want to use that.
We want to have our own,
except then of course
they weren't taking advantage
of the technological advances
that they have.
And there were the chances that
because it wasn't a
sanctioned app for these
particular devices
that it wasn't gonna be able to keep up,
like it wasn't gonna ping as often.
So yeah, it's a mess essentially.
- Let's take a question
question from Maggie, who
I'm gonna give a little
shout out to, hello, Maggie.
Is there any data about the average time
it takes for someone to
no longer be contagious
or recover from COVID-19?
And if so, has there been any
models that take into account
the average amount of
time spent in isolation?
- So the answer to that
is yes, we do know.
I just looked up an actual number
from the World Health Organization.
So they found out that
people with mild disease
recovery times about two weeks,
which is why like my lab had
someone come in from overseas,
right at the very
beginning of the pandemic
and he had to spend two
weeks in total quarantine.
So the recovery time was about two weeks.
And incubation time is shorter than that.
And then people obviously
who get more sick
it's gonna be longer.
Generally they recover
within three to six weeks.
So this is very simple to take
into account in your model.
What was the actual question?
Any models that take into account
the average amount of
time spent in isolation?
Yeah, so I think the standard
isolation period is two weeks.
I've seen several
people, I'm in a new lab,
so a lot of people are
coming in moving around.
So we've had a bunch of people
have to be in isolation.
I think Anna and I had a
friend who moved to Anna's lab
who came in from China
and she had to spend
two weeks in quarantine
before she started working.
So I think that's probably
like their time for isolation.
Cause seems like that's the standard time.
- How's that enforced?
Or is it enforced or is it
sort of like the honor system?
- I think it's honor system.
And I think people, well, I'm
pretty sure the people I know
who've been had to be under quarantine
or has been pretty careful
cause a lot of them are
working in hospitals
cause these are the people, Anna and I-
- [Anna] A really
interesting little factoid
that's tangentially related
that I learned is that,
initially they, I remember
at the start of the pandemic,
there was some talk about the
people who were in isolation
using repeat viral testing.
So the PCR tests to see
if you have virus in you.
Using like negative,
they were trying to use a
negative readings on that
as a criteria for letting
someone out of isolation.
But what we've learned since then is that
the virus actually like
particles of the virus
stay in your system for a very long time,
much longer than the period
through which you're actually infectious.
So you can't use the PCR test really
to determine when someone
is no longer infectious.
Because they can keep showing
up positive on that test
for up to 12 weeks
after they had symptoms.
But they are not, they're
certainly no longer infectious
at that point, the actual
infectious period is much shorter.
- So how do you, I mean,
do you have to just
lean on antibody levels
or how do you make that determination?
- [Anna] Yeah, so the current approach
at least that I'm familiar with
and that I believe they're
using in the hospitals
here in New York or at Mount Sinai
are 10 days from symptom onset.
In addition to being three
days without any fever
or fever reducing medications
and the complete
alleviation of all symptoms.
So it's more a symptom
and time-based metrics.
- Interesting.
- So tying back to the
talk that our colleague
Dr. Odaelys Pollard gave
recently on diabetes,
is there a way to include
diabetes incidents for example,
in this type of model?
- I believe so.
Are we looking at how much
this person is going to suffer
from the disease when they get it?
- Well, I think maybe severity.
I mean aren't diabetic
patients are at higher risk
for more adverse.
- Yeah, they're in one
of the high risk groups.
So this, I think is more modeling spread
rather than actual severity.
And the one parameter I
would think that would affect
the model based on how severe
your symptoms are gonna be
is the amount of time
that you had the virus.
That might affect like how long
you need to be in isolation.
But that's not,
I don't think that's gonna
really affect the model
Anna you can correct me.
- [Anna] I think you're right
in saying that this model
is really just modeling spread.
It's not really looking
at like what's happening
to the people who get sick.
So, but there are other models certainly
that you could incorporate
those sorts of factors into,
I think the SIR model that
was presented on May 20th
that one looks at, people being infected
and then also some
proportion of people being
either recovering or dying.
And so I imagine that you
could elaborate on that model
and incorporate in variables
like the proportion of the
population that is diabetic
and looking at the effect
on that sub-population
within a model like that.
- I guess there is that
one small subset of people
who with regards to smokers,
I don't know if other people read this,
that smoke has potentially
were less likely
to get the infection,
but if they did get it,
they're more likely to have
very adverse effects of symptoms.
- That's weird.
I wonder why that is?
- Yeah, the thing is we don't
want to encourage people
to smoke.
(all laughs)
But yeah, it feels like that
that could be a parameter
that then could potentially plug into
if they're less likely to be infected,
then they're less likely to spread it.
- [Anna] And that's a
parameter that definitely
I could see would vary a
lot country to country.
And so, if you're, you
can take that into account
the differences in populations
between different locations
and that might affect the
sorts of control approaches
that you might want to take.
I think with regard to
some of these different,
these different health considerations.
I was reading a little bit about how,
I think initially everyone
was really concerned
about people with existing
respiratory issues,
people with asthma.
But from what I've read,
it seems like it's turned out to be less,
those people are not
necessarily as much of a concern
or at least asthmatic people aren't.
And that actually, it's
really people with preexisting
like heart disease and heart conditions
because actually the virus really,
there's been a lot of clotting involved
and a lot of damage to the
endothelial lining I believe.
And really it's the cardiovascular system
that really takes a hit in a lot of ways.
So it's a slightly different
population of people
we're starting to learn are at risk
compared to what we initially thought.
- It's just, it seems like
such a complicated biology
and to be in it real time
while also trying to keep our people safe
is not small feat, I think.